se souvenir du passé pour mieux
construire le présent c'est l'objectif
de la ville de Poissy à travers
l'exposition Charles de Gaulle l'homme
derrière le général à l'occasion du 52e
anniversaire de la mort de l'ancien
président l'exposition propose aux
visiteurs de découvrir ou redécouvrir
cette personnalité emblématique du 20e
siècle de sa naissance à sa disparition
il a quand même défendu et met la France
défendue la France
transformer la France si la vie au
service de la nation il a été formé à
ces grandes idées de générosité et de
d'engagement mais je crois que c'est ça
que je souhaiterais transmettre
peut-être aux jeunes et il a fait un
symbole un symbole qui est très fort
c'était la croix de Lorraine là vous
voyez le drapeau des drapeaux de la
résistance avec la fameuse croix de
Lorraine des eaux qui était un symbole
fort face au symbole nazi une exposition
rendue possible grâce aux
collectionneurs pisciake Guy Bouchard il
à disposition de la ville une centaine
de ces pièces authentiques elles
proviennent toutes de sa collection
privée c'est la tenue 31 qu'on appelait
ça 31 pourquoi parce que
c'est elle a été faite du temps de
Napoléon III le 31 juillet 1837 quand on
se met sur 131 c'est rester comme ça
c'était avec la tenue 31 on a réuni deux
collections une connexion sur 14 et
l'école ils sont sur 39-45 on a quand
même à peu près 9000 objets entre objets
documents au lieu de garder dans un
grenier ou garder pour soi ces objets et
ben on préférait aller montrer de vous
montrer ça au public la semaine
l'exposition accueille des classes de
différentes écoles elle sera ouverte au
public le samedi 19 et le dimanche 20
novembre